welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
and The Collector is alive apparently
because the Guardians of the Galaxy
holiday special revealed that it was
indeed he himself Who Sold nowhere to
the Guardians of the Galaxy before the
Guardians converted the space into their
new fancy new HQ but hold on now why the
hell would the collector even sell
nowhere I think he loved that place dorm
in her babies I got you because we gotta
talk about this hey but there is an
explanation that makes sense here but
first do not forget to hit up new
rockstarsmerch.com where you can buy our
new latest Obsession shirts or one of
our amazing other nerd options over
there they have tons of cool stuff for
Christmas for you or the nerdy one in
your family that you love so head on
over to new rockstarbirth.com today
alright so we're all wondering why did
the collectors sell nowhere to the
Guardians of the Galaxy the very same
people mind you that were directly
responsible for the destruction of this
collection facility in the first movie
well the answer to this makes sense if
we consider what was established about
the collector in Guardians 1 because
recap The Collector is the former owner
of nowhere who hands down had the
largest collection of stuff in the
universe and needless to say that
collection very problematic because he
didn't just regulate his collection to
meet trinkets knickknacks and or Paddy
wax oh no that's great with the frosted
tips put whole ass people with families
in cages like this dark elf as well as
everyone's favorite telekinetic Russian
dog Cosmo the space dog an eternal hater
of raccoons that we finally got to catch
up with in the Guardians of the Galaxy
holiday special as she helps the
Guardians get their new place up
what I refuse to do any more work while
you demand me however the collector
didn't set up shop inside of a giant
Celestial head just to be a pack rat he
was there for a specific purpose of
purpose that Gamora tells the Guardians
about when they first arrive at nowhere
in Guardians 1. hundreds of years ago
the Tavon group sent workers in to mine
the organic matter with skull bone brain
tissue spinal fluid all rare resources
highly valued in Black markets across
the Galaxy
it's dangerous and illegal work suitable
only for outlaws the only reason why the
collector was that nowhere was
specifically to mine the celestial
material out of nowhere severed head to
sell on the black market to sketchy
entities underneath the policing eyes of
the interstellar Nova Corps catchy
people like probably the high
evolutionary and this is very much in
line to what Thanos says of the
collector in Avengers Infinity War while
he is crushing the collector's sternum
the slightest trinket to your pathetic
collection and although it sounds like
Thanos is just straight up roasting The
Collector he actually really wasn't
because that's literally what the
collector would do because everything
that tanaleer Travon does he does for
the specific purpose of his eternal
hobby of collecting an obsession that
Benicio del Toro himself has stated is
directly linked to The Collector for
seeing a coming Cosmic disaster for all
of life in the universe you know kind of
like how Noah collected all the animals
into the ark before the worldwide flood
in the Bible he's kind of like Noah from
Noah's Ark he believes that there's
going to be a big catastrophe in the
galaxy and of course the collector would
unfortunately be proven right with
thanos's universal snap alright guys I'm
on camera a lot so I have to see my face
a lot so you think I'd have to put a lot
of effort into my skincare routine but I
don't because I use geology geology is a
15 time award-winning personalized skin
care company recognized in hypebeast
birdie Men's Health Esquire and ask man
grooming Awards with over 6 1000 5 Star
reviews that is a lot of thousands
that's six of them and they've recently
expanded to offer products for pretty
much whatever you need all you've got to
do is take a quick 30 second diagnostic
quiz and geology figures out your
routine for you if you need Hair Care
not me use geology's co-wash a specially
formulated cream cleanser that removes
buildup and cleanses the hair without
the big lather or harsh ingredients of
typical shampoo and for the rest of your
shower routine you can use their body
washes that are free of harsh
ingredients smell grades and are
refillable and for after the shower
protect your skin from environmental
stressors with vitamin c and e for Rolex
serum to keep your skin looking young
and healthy and then a bit of
dermatologist tested aluminum-free
deodorant that quite honestly smells
great like I've gotten so many
compliments from the ladies specifically
so and right now for a limited time
geology is hooking our audience up with
an absolutely insane insanity if you use
code do rock stars that will give you an
additional 70 off their award-winning
skin care trial set that's seven zero
percent seventy that discount applies
whether your stocking up for yourself or
stuffing someone else's stocking instead
either way geology has you covered check
out their awesome gift sets featuring
all your favorite geology products to
get started just click the link in the
description take a 30 second diagnostic
quiz and their team of dermatologists
will design a personalized routine just
for you that ships directly to your door
however if you live a long life of
wanting everything you still have to
deal with the fact that capitalism is a
[ __ ] and even in space and things still
cost money and this being said it's the
reason why the collector was at nowhere
was to mine Celestial material for the
sake of making money so that he can buy
more stuff and kidnap more people he
can't really do that if say I don't know
a purple pain in half of the universe's
ass decided to destroy all of your
Celestial material that you were selling
from the inside out which is exactly
what Thanos ended up doing after his
short trip to Nowhere in Infinity War
incinerating the collector's museum with
the Power Stone yet again after the
Guardians did so in Guardians 1. so with
all that Celestial material of nowhere
Burns to a crisp along with all of his
collection canaler Travon literally had
no other reason to stay inside of
nowhere's head anymore because at the
end of the day the collector is a
businessman who wants money to feed his
obsession so because nowhere can no
longer make him money by providing him
with a valuable Black Market resource
The Collector decided to sell nowhere's
useless husk of a skeleton to the
Guardians to make his last chunk of
money from nowhere before heading off to
one of his many other collections
throughout the Galaxy as James Gunn has
revealed in a past interview with Empire
though like nowhere was not his only
collection in the universe and this is
undoubtedly where the Guardians also got
Cosmo the space dog from because as we
know from the very end of Guardians 1
Cosmo was actually quite friendly with
his captor The Collector even going as
far as licking his wounds after the
Guardians blew up his house Peter Quill
being the homesick Terran boy that he is
likely had the collector include Cosmo
in the nowhere purchase but yeah that's
basically it the collectors sold nowhere
because Thanos removed all the value
from nowhere after he used the Power
Stone to blow it up but this sort of
makes me wonder if the collector has
even more cholesterol body parts and
organs that he has in mind in the
universe that he can collect later on
only time will tell but thank you guys
so much for watching this video you can
follow me at mastertainment on Twitter
if you want to see me tweet some weird
[ __ ] and insane theories but most
importantly you can follow into
rockstars wherever we are on the
internet and of course do not forget to
hit up new rockstarsmerch.com where you
can buy all of our amazing new nerd
options and shirts and all of our cool
stickers and pins and all of our amazing
nerd stuff over there just in time for
Christmas head on over there today but
yes thank you guys again for watching
this video I love you guys times a
million I will see you guys next time
goodbye
[Music]